democrats accused former president trump
of a judicial coup de time when he
filled vacancies on the federal bench
but as of last week president biden has
actually nominated more people for the
federal bench than president trump did
during his first year in office
judicial vacancies are important for
many reasons including the right to a
speedy trial and the efficient
adjudication of civil claims but there
is a constitutional process which
includes the advice and consent of the
united states senate federal judges are
appointed for life that is a long time
presidents appoint women and men to the
federal bench who will assuredly be in
office long after the president's gone
and very likely be in office long after
the senators themselves are gone some
federal judges have served for over half
a century
so is it really asking too much that
these senators be allowed to meet with
these nominees before actually voting on
them
judges not only serve for life but they
make important decisions such as passing
senates and criminal cases and
adjudicating the constitutionality of
laws and regulations it's an important
job
which is why u.s senators have a role to
play in the selection of these women and
men
federal judges include both trial judges
who serve in one state and circuit court
of appeals judges who issue orders and
opinions that impact multiple states
for instance south carolina is in the
same judicial circuit with north
carolina virginia maryland and west
virginia judges nominated in south
carolina are likely to have an impact on
the lives of people living in maryland
or west virginia so of course senators
from those states will want to meet and
vet those nominees
except they can't
despite the historical norms and the
importance of the positions and the life
tenure and the power federal judges have
the bible administration apparently
doesn't want senators meeting with the
very women and men they have to vote on
and who will be making decisions which
impact their states
dan sullivan is a united states senator
from alaska alaska is in the ninth
judicial circuit a circuit that includes
eight other states
but the decisions made by the ninth
circuit impact alaska so of course
senator sullivan wants to meet with
these nominees
except he can't
he's been denied meetings with
prospective judges maybe he votes for
these nominees or maybe he does not but
he's not even allowed to meet with them
and that doesn't make a lot of sense to
me
or to him
senator sullivan joins us now thank you
for joining us senator i actually
watched your conversation with senator
whitehouse from rhode island on the
senate floor it was cordial as most
senate conversations are
but i do not understand the explanation
for why
you cannot meet with judicial nominees
whose decisions impact your very state
well trey listen uh i'm really glad
you're raising this topic and by the way
merry christmas
great to be on the show but here's the
thing this this administration with some
democratic allies in the house
and senate has been smashing key
constitutional norms as you know they're
trying to pack the supreme court look at
elizabeth warren just announced that
they're trying to kill the filibuster
and then this one comes up
trying to undermine the advice and
consent role that the u.s senate has
with regard to nominees especially as
you mentioned
judges who have life tenure
so i've been fighting this and i'm i'm
actually glad to report right now that
we finally have a victory in this one we
have stopped in its tracks
this latest attack on the constitution
and constitutional norms but i'll tell
you this was a breathtaking overreach
another one by the biden white house
well good for you senator how in the
world because i watched i think it was
just this week i watched you in senator
whitehouse
i think you had you would put a hold on
something until they just simply let you
meet so how did you pull this off
well look i called the white house the
biden white i said what the heck's going
on i meet with every ninth circuit judge
no matter what as you mentioned in your
piece already the ninth circuit has
enormous power over my constituents they
often get legal cases
wrong so i said are you the one white
house counsel is not letting me do my
advice and consent role as a u.s senator
you know it's hard to tell who's in
charge over there in the white house
she actually said well we want to
protect
our judges i said protect our judges
what the heck are you talking about
protect them from what us doing our
constitutional duty so i put holds on
these judges and i got all my senate
colleagues to
commit to voting against every
biden judicial nominee and then i
started talking to democrats senators
too and to be honest i think i convinced
some of them to say we're not going to
do this we're not going to undermine the
senate's advice and consent power
so we played hardball and finally i
started getting some meetings with these
judges who are up for life tenure
appointments will have enormous power
over my state and the whole you know
ninth circuit trade you know that's one
out of five americans but this again is
just another power grab and an
undermining of constitutional norms we
got to keep fighting we had a victory on
this one but there's a lot more of the
constitution we ought to protect
you know senator they do serve a life
they make incredibly
challenging difficult decisions i've
been lucky every federal judge i've
appeared in front of would have you
would have been proud of whether you
voted for them or nominated them or not
they were wonderful but the issue of
temperament will that robe get heavy
will you change how do you make that
call if you've never met or talked to
the person in person
well here it's you're exactly right and
here's what i did in these meetings when
i finally was able to have them again
i've met with every ninth circuit uh
judge by the way every dc circuit judge
every supreme court justice of course
it's a huge part of our job it's article
two section 2 of the us constitution the
notion that the white house would say
you can't do that under the constitution
because we want to protect
judges is just crazy but when it comes
to the issues of temperament or their
knowledge what i do in in cases with
ninth circuit judges trey i send them
several u.s supreme court cases that
have an impact on alaska i ask them to
read them so they're up to speed on big
issues in my state and then i talk about
issues like the second amendment you
know let me give you an example almost
70 percent of the households in alaska
are gun owners i mean the second
amendment is hugely important to my
constituents so i raise the issues that
matter to alaska and to be honest these
judges usually don't know anything about
these issues and it's a way to educate
them so when they're on the bench for
life they are doing things that
represent everybody in the entire
circuit not just where they're from and
unfortunately in my case california
produces the vast majority of the ninth
circuit judges alaska gets one judge out
of 29 so you better believe i'm going to
interview every single one of them we
finally
fought back and won against this latest
biden attack on the constitution
well senator uh just to show you how
much of a nerd i am i was actually
watching c-span so i listened to it and
that's what piqued my interest
congratulations
to you for getting this
resolved you know life is a long time
you have a job for six years mine is
sort of day to day or night tonight but
life is a long time so kudos to you for
staying on it and getting it resolved
merry christmas to the entire sullivan
family and thank you for being with us
tonight
thank you trey merry christmas to you
and your family as well hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else